okay guys something on a special video
for you today so recently I celebrated
my five-year anniversary on YouTube and
kind of as a thank you and also just
because I haven't done for a very long
time
I thought I do question-answer session
now questions I left on my previous blog
and you can answer them now I'm from the
Netherlands and I'm watching our videos
but what's the most interesting country
get used from one YouTube now this is
interesting because the UN defines that
there are 206 sovereign nations in the
world and according to YouTube I've have
views from 222 so I think YouTube might
be making places up but I just I
scrolled to the places where I've had
like one or two views for over the
lifetime of my channel and it's places
like American Samoa the Central African
Republic menaced on Naruto go Burundi
literally every country I think in the
world which is mental when you think
about it Shivani Rembrandt you're
awesome by the way asks who's your
favorite scientist it's tough
actually I always had a really soft spot
for Paul Dirac because he was like
something else he was just maths genius
and I'm such a different plane that he
shared very little with other than mere
mortals but I've also also read like
Michael Faraday who was a really nice
guy who from all accounts I missed this
genius experimental physicist team that
in all of his notebooks there's not a
single equation in yet he was so
instrumental to the work that happened
and the physicist after him actually if
I do pick one it would probably be one
of the people that used Friday's when I
was doing Scott Maxwell because he was
he was a mixture of the two
he was this theorist he was absolutely
brilliant he did the second great
unification in physics after Newton and
he was also a brownie just a really
really lovely sweet guy who was very
caring so yeah
that Maxwell well how long did it take
for you to decide what your PhD would be
about well when I applied for my PhDs
and stuff I was accepted to Exeter if
you've watched my job my life you'll
know that this this wasn't the PhD that
actually applied for I was basically
told it was on stratosphere stratosphere
troposphere coupling so I kind of knew
the field it was gonna be in but I
didn't know what my research project was
it actually took me about a year of
reading through papers trying things out
doing a bit of exploring data
exploration before I really knew what I
wanted it to be about and now I've got a
definite research question it took about
a year I guess of a relatively in-depth
trying to think of a question will you
be doing videos on their PhD yes I will
be definitely there's a series on the
stratosphere coming up quite soon
so are we doing that what do you lost
most about physics and which topics your
favorite I guess that's meant to be
loved most about physics if that is what
you meant then it's magic that's what I
like about physics I like the fact that
it takes a quantity which you know and
it with a little bit of trickery and
math it gives you a quantity in the end
that you didn't know before so you know
you know how much something weighs and
how much initially moves and given what
surfaces are little physics will tell
you how far I will make that's
essentially imagining right if it's
telling you information you don't
otherwise know that's why I left in
terms of my favorite topics I realize I
do really like fluid mechanics which I
use a fair bit at the moment using
primitive equations in the atmosphere
but I also I really like special
relativity there's a very when you do
special relativity appeal back then for
vectors it's very very pure and I really
like that about it
yeah there's very few things like
physics like the very few topics either
undergraduate I really disliked I don't
know I guess I try to approach every day
for mine I love a lot of it you know if
only you were gay
sigh sorry
I thought there's not much we can say
about that there are a few questions
like this I'm just going to pick this
one from Spanglish Hannah could you do a
video explaining your PhD what it is you
have to do and your daily life and stuff
like that
now I will be doing a day in the life of
PhD student that I'll hope even quite
seen actually because it's still term
time it won't be for very much longer so
yeah definitely to do a daily life
that's a helicopter ignore that like
that's the hospital I think but I would
also really like to do a video
explaining what my PhD is about I'm
gonna be doing talking about the
stratosphere in this series that's
coming up soon but and the last video
that is basically gonna talk about what
I do I would like at some point there to
do a video just a quick one explaining
the mic project but I've also I don't
know I don't know if then people would
be interested as I was thinking other
day of there are a lot of very abstract
concepts that I don't fully understand
yet in my field and maybe making a quick
three-minute video about this concept of
explaining it to a lay audience would be
a good way for me to understand it you
know if that's something that you might
find useful then you know give me a
shout in the comments bye Simon in one
of your videos you mentioned that you
somehow failed your first year
undergraduate how did you pick yourself
up after that like what exactly we may
try to biology to your daily schedule
more seriously etc Thanks
it's tough question to answer actually I
think I just it wasn't so much motivated
by a particular thing other than just I
didn't do well at this and that's not
what I do i do well things so I'm gonna
do it again but I'm gonna do way way
better I don't know I don't know if
there's anything more fundamental than
that it was just driving me to do well
cuz that was that's my thing in terms of
I picked myself up that was tough that
was there was there was a few days of
soul-searching when I was coming is this
really for me am I good enough to do
this and I sort of them well let's try
again and if I'm not good enough I'm not
good enough we'll do something else but
there's no point you're just rolling
over and giving up you've got to try at
least so that's what I do okay this is a
long one I'll warn you now
hey silent my question is to what extent
do you think theoretical physics is a
useful career to enter especially
considering the fact that is sometimes
much at stake on many one or many
theories of / ideas apologies have a
scent a bit i naive
I'm currently state my first trip a
levels and I was wondering what your
take on the flattery as soon as you
studied subject whilst you're an
undergrad now it's very important to
realize and this happens all the time of
physics if you are studying physics and
undergraduate and theoretical physics
you know you say specifically that
doesn't mean that's all you're going to
do for the rest of your career so most
people will study physics and then go
off and do something else like banking
or programming or another degree or
teaching or anything really it's very
unusual that people will take the
material from their course exclusively
get out of the restaurant
what theoretical physics does and theory
more than other parts of physics is it
gives you a tool kit that you can use in
other situations it's very logical it's
very mathematical and so if you do
theoretical physics or physics generally
it makes you employable in a huge number
of fields basically anything that's even
vaguely technical would be interested in
having you because
you know it's almost like I don't know
it's almost like if you got really good
to say football that doesn't just mean
that you can only do football it means
you also better equipped to do hockey or
rugby or something because you've built
up a physical tool kit that you can use
to other situations with physics it's
exactly the same is just mental rather
than physical so don't be worried about
applying physics and thinking there's no
career prospects because they really are
just follow what you're interested in
and that's the best decision you can
make what's your favorite book I about
this I was thinking about this ages the
other day choosing one is really
difficult because I love lots of
different books of different reasons I
love for example brave new world bolas
actually because it made me think for
the first time more seriously about
societal issues I lost 60 pieces by
finally because it really got me into
physics if I had to pick one book it
would be my family other animals by gel
dull because it's a nice easy read it's
really sweet it's perfect like relaxing
it's perfect for relaxing too and it
really got me going on environmentalism
and conservation laws kid so it's
important to me as well if you haven't
read it absolutely go check it out you
will not regret it I'm changing hands
because this apparently ways of tongue
living on point have asked like a
million questions right number one are
you a nerdfighter dftba inhale again
number two what do you think are the
most important qualities that happens
you want to study physics what abilities
did you work on for taking my degree
nice basically my physics at uni is
basically the same as master class a
lover at least it was to me particularly
the mechanic side of things that's it
was at height half of my first year work
on maths
probably good a day to work on a program
you as well because a lot of physics
courses mine did involve at least a
programming component and my research
now is almost entirely it so maps and
programming number three how do you
tackle school related anxiety and stress
make sure you're allocating a pine in
your in your schedule for doing not work
things I started meditation when I was
at uni and that really helped
yeah it's basically it's like studying
the point major my studying Buddha is
basically a very individual thing so do
whatever it takes for you to chop
I'm just gonna talk claim that shower
originally before last thing I want to
read something explodes I forgot my
personal statement and guessing the ship
just be popular science but we can't
find any reading lists do you have any
physics books at the good in the pattern
statement that was our generally good
informative books I did a two-part
physics but recommendations video if you
haven't already seen that I'll put a
link in the description in addition to
that I pretty sure that Oxford makes its
physics reading this public so if you
con the physics website physics
department website proxy and this
students probably then check it out
there was probably something Jeremy
Clark my surname I have a question that
our oxygen cameras the be all and end
all the science academia every watch do
physics by for London University so my
hand from a possible future career no no
you're not that you're not hampering
future career and they're not the be-all
and end-all fundamentally oxidant
Cambridge are just you needs that are
very good at science there are other
uses that are also very good at science
like Imperial and Manchester
so go where if you're going to be happy
don't feel like you have to apply to
Oxbridge if it's not right for you so
maybe performs the trap go to Oxbridge
and I'm not happy so really consider
what's going to make you happy and
what's best for you and do that then
lastly there's been a whole series of
questions like this I'm gonna pick
perspect all just a question what's your
fitness routine and is that an important
part the life do you believe that being
fair that helped academic performance so
I started trying to take my fitness
seriously in my third year Oxford and
trying to lose their way and get more in
shape I sort of did that a little bit in
Oxford but in the since I moved to
Exeter I'm really lucky in the x-star
the from normal gym and I'm also now
live with a housemate who's a qualified
personal trainer and nutritionist so
I've got access to like this sense I who
I can ask questions off and I try and
work out at the moment I'm on a bulking
phase to answer somebody else's question
about is my chest getting bigger every
video hopefully yes and I'm trying to
work out three days a week with lifting
heavy weights and I meant to be doing
cardio two days a week but that hasn't
really been happening recently because
I'm not the word lazy but I do think
it's important to do I mentioned this in
my you how study about any video
I think I think it's an important part
of being around an individual being fit
and healthy and strong anyway but I
think it's really important to exercise
this chance to blossom steam you know if
you're studying all day you need the
chance just to really vents and
frustration and particularly I
personally find lifting weights very
cathartic because you can vent all your
frustrations in this way push this
everything away from me it's kind of
what you want to do with all your
studying but it's a bit irresponsible
and somebody else asked how much do you
bench squat and deadlift know enough if
the short runs for that I squat like the
I mean I've not done a 1 rep max I don't
know exactly how much I could on each
one i bench like 60 kilos score about 70
dead leg vanity if you took in a long
set to say a traps and five or six sets
which I really like puts me in the
category of not very strong people but
I've only been lifting with a bar for
just every year so I'm relatively new to
all this but I'm getting there with this
bulky base actually improving a lot so
things crossed I'll get those figures
we'll get bigger the next time I do
another Q&A video so thank you everyone
who sent in those questions I'm really
sorry feels didn't get right out
basically I don't want this video to be
million years old I think I've covered
all the basic by territory that people
wanted covered so thank you again for
subscribing to me and for supporting me
over the past five years on YouTube and
I put a like that that is mental that's
a substantial fraction of my life I've
been making videos it wouldn't be
possible if you guys didn't actually
enjoy the content I put out and stay
with me so thank you honestly say master
Dana
next week there will be a video on could
be the applying toxin Cambridge video
next week where we are sort of laying
out all the resources and talking
through any possible question you might
have and between then there's also Kenny
Moore XCOM so stick around for that and
thank you very much for watching if you
like this like it and do all the things
that youtubers tell you to do the end of
videos and subscribe and like and check
out all my merch and yeah all that stuff
and lots of hand waving around here do
lots of hand waving anyway bye